good morning believe nation how you
today happy friday welcome to gratitude
journal live stream number 45 i'm
feeling that a lot better i'm almost
there just a little bit tail end at the
end there left but getting super-close
so i'm excited to be back with you guys
we do this every day weekdays sharing
what we're grateful for it's important
to have grateful happy entrepreneurs out
there changing lives changing the world
for the better so i'm going to list
three things i'm grateful for you guys
list your three in the chat youse guys
watch it afterwards youse guyses had
yous guys leave it in comments below and
make sure its daily make sure it's
consistent and make sure you feel what
you're saying and not just type out
three things have a have a quick quiet
moment of reflection on those three
things when it means to you everyday let
make a big difference in your life so
i'm going to start off number one it's
its remembrance day here in canada think
in the u.s. it's memorial thing is it
what more did I get that right Iran let
me check that quick to my Google
Calendar I think it'll veterans day at
Memorial is veterans it's basically the
same thing um basically the day to think
about the people who sacrifice their
lives for the country and I you know we
don't really think that much about it I
don't really talk about it I don't
really think about it that much often
but we are pretty fortunate to live in a
pretty peaceful time where you don't
have to wake up you know worrying if
you're going to get bombed or not maybe
some of you guys are in different
countries that you're watching from but
in general it's a pretty pretty peaceful
world in comparison to what some of our
ancestors had to go through so super
grateful for that and all the people who
allowed that to happen for us Canada's
played a peacekeeping role in the world
in general which I'm super proud of and
hopefully we'll continue with so just
thankful for all the people who
sacrificed their lives for us to have
freedom and peace and just quiet moan
reflection there for that I think
actually the leben you're supposed to
are you suppose that eleven o'clock have
a minute of silence at least we do it
here in canada since every minute a
member of school we'd have to everything
to be an announcement on the bell on the
PA system and then be like everybody
moment of silence boonton to think about
the veterans to us my number one number
two I'm people for a gri sending me some
I think one of those things called quick
blast um it's this echinacea pill in the
liquid cap that when you chew it just
shoots hey Kenisha up your face and
clears everything up momentarily and so
it was super helpful yesterday I had
meetings and heads in my audiobook the
last day um actually if you drink water
after that it like a hyper charges it's
crazy I didn't know that it's already
like everything is on fire like in a
good way just but then if you drink
water just takes it to a new level so
that was unexpected so that was the
photos hit the I wasn't prepared for
that at the interesting surprise
yesterday so ji ups uh it was overnight
it was the same day yeah it was anyway
hehe ups this quick blast to uh to my
door so that I would have that so much
appreciative that jer I spreading the
love uh and number three I would say
yeah it's so it's nina's last day at her
job she's taking a new job starting next
week and I think I'm can I guess I'm
grateful for that I'm happy for her in
that it's a new adventure for her at the
start I know she's kind of nervous as
well as excited you know sad to leave
the place that she's been at for a
number of years and built some really
solid friendships but you know also
excited and nervous to go to a new place
and make new friendships and I think
just you know when you see somebody
going through a big change in their life
it makes you reflect
on the relationship that you've had with
them so now she's she's here in the
photos and super grip over business she
does for me I'm because you guys can't
see it but I'm staring at like a a desk
full of food and beverage and she made
me extra smoothies to try to help me get
better and eggs and lentils and tea and
thing of vitamins in any way lots of
love for Nina I couldn't do what I do
without the support of Nina so I don't
know if she's watching but happy last
day and super excited for the new job if
she starts on Monday so we've got a
couple minutes left I want to jump to
the live chat see what you guys are
grateful for zeno's starting us off hey
y'all what do you do before today make
sure you don't just list some things
they actually feel them in your bones I
love it sharing the message man ah
Zeno's grateful for number one once
again the love and support from believe
nation is probably the most common thing
I share as something I'm good before but
there's a good reason for it I love the
two man i love you guys too number two
my cats they're very very lazy and one
of them always walks away when I want to
give her a hug but they're super cute
such a CAD a you want to get them love
and they walk away with dogs always want
to give you love in any way I'm a dog
person mmm and although a lot of times
they don't they don't reply I love
talking to them very cool number three
for not being a cyclist good for not
being a cyclist recent even hears in
Holland it's like it's like yeah
everybody's on a bicycle uh I live in
was probably the bicycle capital of the
world there you go but cyclists are the
worst and I don't want any part of it
say no I don't know if that's gratitude
made I don't know that's gratitude but
grateful for being a pedestrian I guess
thank you for sharing best you pro great
love for one another beautiful day on
this island
jamaica gotta get the jamaica I've been
to Jamaica I figured where I landed in
Jamaica I was on a cruise reggae makes
everything better it's true I do like
reggae to for the internet for allowing
us to connect with like-minded people
and customers from all over the world
love that three for completing our first
ebook congratulations would really love
if you guys can give us some feedback on
the first chapter it is available for
free download on our website all right
congratulations on ebook super exciting
her uh yes jerez is asking where can you
get it what you want to give you
feedback tell tell tell us where you can
get the best you Pro ebook and what the
topic is what is it about uh relax and
sleep station I'm grateful for our
cleaning lady she does an amazing job
making a house so clean and she does it
with a happy attitude very cool i love
that too i'm grateful for the mist I saw
today on the tree tops on my morning
walk it helps me feel connected to
nature which isn't always easy in a city
of 15 million people wow that's a big
city 15 million people 15 million people
he's got to be somewhere in China 15
million people yeah uh 3 i'm grateful
for the ebook ascent the the books are
the book essentialism by greg emma
mckeon mckee own essentialism that i've
just finished reading it was full of
great insights into managing what
projects i should prioritize and which
ones I shouldn't very cool thank you for
the recommendations Oh is from grunt
gwangsu China all right there you go 15
million people I love it um what else we
got what else we got we got some chatter
we got some chatter out of the website
is best you procomp there you go Thanos
pulling that
what else what else what else Mitchell
today I'm grateful for one single steam
or cycling where the different items are
sorted for you that's pretty cool single
steamers have never heard of our names
single stream Oh single stream I still
never heard of that home cities have it
we're like you just throw everything and
the stream sorts that I like you'll how
does it know what what's plastic and
what's newspaper and what's technology
yeah well that's pretty cool i like that
i wish we had that yeah single so single
stream single stream recycling I like it
ought to believe team and three
nonprofits pretty cool thank you man uh
what else we got J reyez thankful for
deep breaths which instantly calm soothe
and access wellbeing for restaurants
that serve me food in dough dishes
what's that do and do dishes food and oh
I you know I think it food in co or
something I said dough food and do
dishes good times for couriers just let
me transport things by barely lifted a
finger yeah alright very cool and now
let's end on much I'm people for all the
veterans day and all the people that
have fought for our freedom in the
military and otherwise awesome thank you
guys for the fun happy gratitude Friday
we're gonna hop on to twitch we haven't
done it in a couple days and see on my
voice at holds up so you can join us
there if I don't see you there though
hope you have an amazing friday I
believe in you hoping continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon